lucille wall is the most iconic person  in the history of american villains she  was a visionary she was a revolutionary  she was a woman  that really made a lot for women in the  industry  they were the first to show pregnancy on  television it's crazy 60 million  we're watching  every monday night  ladies and gentlemen and join us all  it's something that has never been  duplicated and never will we're talking  about the 50s in the united states on a  show  run by a woman and a foreigner that's a  lot she had a fluidity to her comedy  that it never felt forced  it was incredibly organic action  and what she did with uh harper max when  she mimics  what he does i think it's brilliant the  chocolate factory where the chocolate  gets out of control it's popping them in  her mouth he's like hold up how  how do you do that it's it's they were  geniuses  [Music]  [Applause]